no one's going to fix your life but you
you always have to take a step up in the
ladder to be able to get to the top you
can't get to the top by flying up human
beings don't fly for me what has always
worked is
having the small next dream you know uh
the next step when I was younger it was
really romanticized that you're going
for it and just keep going and you know
it's like you have to work 24 hours do
four movies in one time you know five
shifts don't sleep don't eat and the
more a person does that the more
successful you will be but as I have
seen and lived more life I've realized
having a work-life balance is really
important give yourself a break it's
okay you just have to do the best you
can survive keep your head above water
and slowly you see you'll be walking on
it so this romanticization of work has
to be tough and work has to be rough and
it's not work can be your companion work
and be creative work can be something
that gives you Joy and now I've reached
a point
where that work-life balance for me is
most important I will work on the six
verticals that I'm working on you know
my business my production my book my
acting whatever
but when I switch off I'm with my family
I'm at home I watch movies I do whatever
I want to do so then when I come back to
work the next day I have the focus to be
able to do even more things I started
working in the states in 2010 and in 201
2 after 10 years of working in the
industry I started with music and then
pivoted into acting in America so
started in 2010 for context in 2020 I
got my first leading role how long did
it take me
10 years
so people don't think about how much
hard work how much consistent knocking
on doors how much humility it takes to
go to another country and start from
scratch
but it required me to strip every single
thing that I knew in India and The
Laurels that I had achieved in India the
awards that I had won the movies that I
had done the box office successes that I
had seen it required me to walk into
rooms with extreme humility and
introduce myself to people to take my
show real and say this is the work I
have done I would love to work with you
you have to go you have to pound the
pavement you have to walk in you have to
be rejected you have to audition and you
have to work around the culture of a new
country and that was so hard I had to
swallow the humility pill and I was
willing to do that hard work and then 10
years later I finally got my leading
role in a movie the tears that it took
when you moved to a new country with no
friends no family working with people
that don't know you and don't know what
you are able to achieve when I first
started doing Quantico my co-actors did
not understand the hoopla around me they
were like why is like who is this person
like why are you you know the leader of
that was the first time I got a lead
role in a television series and they
just couldn't understand why and it it
required me to just you know be humble
and say I'm okay this is a new
environment it's it's easy to go you
know fishing from your boat but when you
have to go deep sea diving it's a
completely different thing so you have
to learn according to your environment
so no it wasn't easy it was very hard it
took a lot of sweat tears and blood from
me to finally be able to reach where I
have reached So when you say you know I
don't want to pass off
um the work that it took to get there
and the time and the commitment that it
took to get there you have to shut off
the noise there are many people that
will want to pull you down but don't
focus on that focus on the one person
that believes in you focus on the light
little sliver of light that you might
see a little bit of inspiration that you
might see and that's the hardest thing
to do because you're bogged down by
baggage you're bogged down by shackles
of people holding you down so you have
to really push forward and that's just
individual do you have that inside of
you to fight that fight for yourself or
are you going to wait for somebody else
to do it that's an individual choice
the point is to be able to walk into a
room and not be judgy and say who are
you what are you doing you don't you
know you're different you speak a
different language that's not cool
people speak different languages because
they know more than you they know other
things that you don't know the idea is
to have your mind open to collaboration
the idea is to have your mind open to
what is it that I can imbibe from
someone else's knowledge and I think I'm
a student of life I love different kinds
of people and different things that
people do
I'm not running as fast as I was I'm
thinking about the steps I take I'm in a
really comfortable content place when it
comes to my life and the choices that
I'm making are mine and are not defined
by
other people or the validation that I
probably needed when I was younger so I
think that's made me a little bit more
happy and calm why am I lucky enough to
have the life that I do and some other
woman somewhere else with the same
desires same Ambitions same you know
needs doesn't have any of it I really
think about that a lot it makes me feel
like there must be something I did right
I wake up every day with a sense of
gratitude and I wake up every day with
wanting to give back whether that's with
the person that is standing right next
to me or whether that is a life choice
that I might make but giving back I
think is so crucial when it comes to
being grateful I'm highly grateful for
everything that I have and I do think
that maybe I did something right that
I've been blessed with the opportunity
of having the life being born to the
parents that I was being able to have
the opportunity of making my own choices
having agency in my own life life if you
think about women around the world
so many don't have that the complete
choices are made for themselves but my
parents told me you have to have your
opinion it can be very scary I mean this
generation of girls is fearless and
there's so many girls that take charge
of their own lives and they say you know
I'm not going to fit into the cookie
cutter mold that probably my mother did
or my grandmother had to and it's so
like I have Goosebumps right now just
thinking about it I meet so many young
women who have changed the trajectory of
their families because of the choices
that they've made I think my message
would be that there's a lot of noise
around us and people that tell us to be
a certain way I was talking the other
day about someone that when I went to
convent school I had this thing called
moral science a subject called moral
science which taught me how women should
be seen not heard the lengths of our
skirts how we should sit with our legs
um there's so much that has been told to
women that to be a good girl you have to
be a certain way
Good Girls Don't Make History Bold Girls
Make History bold people make history so
if you want to be the lead actor of the
of your movie which is your life you've
got to take choices that might be
contrary to what you've heard and that
empowerment may or may not come from
your parents may or may not come from
your family or boyfriend or whoever
you're around it comes from you and that
no one can do if you don't have that
encouragement in your home try to find
it in your gut because No One's Gonna
fix your life but you
I don't know I don't think about the
future I'm not someone who I plan for
the future but I don't think about how
far I can go I mean who knows what my
future holds for me but what I can think
about is my present and like I said I
like to imbibe from people that I know
the reason I take new steps is because I
see someone else doing something new and
I'm like what can I do that'll make me
feel how I feel about this person it's
about that feeling it's about imbibing
from the people around you and it could
be someone you admire on television it
could be someone in your class it could
be someone that you work with but when
you see something that you admire about
someone imbibit and I just love the fact
that you can have an idea today and
monetize it why not you're not just
reduced to I won't say reduced to
because I come from a family of doctors
and Engineers but at that time in my
parents generation and the generation
before that it was Doctor engineer
lawyer military government job like
those five or six things that everyone
had to aim aim for but today like I
think my generation of parents are not
going to have those boxes for our
children right you have an idea let's
run with it I think that Innovation is
the only way to evolve and if you're not
evolving you're stagnant it's boring bye
you should go to bed so I think but for
me I that's a little bit of a struggle
for me I I juggle a lot of balls and
sometimes I'm just so tired that I don't
pay attention to the next thing as much
as I would want to
and I checked the Box sometimes and it
works and it's okay because a lot of us
do it we just like you know go to work
and do the bare minimum and I have to
remind myself that the bare minimum is
not my standard for myself it always has
to be more than the minimum and you have
to remind yourself to take some time you
just have to take some time to like you
know whatever you want to do go to bed
early have ice cream just feed your soul
when you feed your soul as a human being
when you're with your family your
friends you laugh a little you ha you
know bring joy Innovation happens
creativity comes from place of feeling
good with yourself and I think the most
important thing is to feed who you are
and then it just does what is my best
opportunity at 18 at 25 at 35 at 60. who
is it that you want to be so aging
nothing but a number that's a real real
fact we put too much equity on age it
just doesn't matter what matters is what
you do about your life in the moment
right now
keep the people around you that are your
Champions and maybe this is also
something I realize when I'm older but I
tell young people this all the time do
not hang around with poisonous people do
not keep people around you that are
toxic that mess with your brain keep
people around you that are genuinely
happy with happy for you only people
that are genuinely happy for you and
whether if that's two people you're a
rich person I think the meaning of life
is having purpose
we're born and will die
what you do in between that is your
legacy and if your legacy is you know
walking with sand between your toes and
living in a shack and and being happy
and meditating sure it's an individual
Choice success is very subjective
to each person is their own My Success
might be completely not attractive to
somebody else's success the equity that
we put on you know your most successful
one of the most successful people on the
planet would have a great that's my
version of it but somebody else's
version of it could be completely
different but I really believe that what
your purpose in life and what you do
between birth and death is is what
counts so the pursuit of anything else
is just futile the pursuit should be
what am I doing in my life what do I
want to do in my life who do I want to
be who do I want to touch what do I want
to create do I want to create or maybe I
don't want to create and all of it is
fine as long as you are at peace with
the choices you make so make choices
that make you feel peaceful